Phoebe hey hey look I was wondering if
maybe you wanted to hang out
it's the last summer after high school
ends the last chance to decide who we
want to be and who we want to be with I
give up
and you supposed to wear to a breakup
how about we agree to stay friends just
friends okay
walk away
oh for God's sakes this gonna be the
summer it's clean slate
you're really good believe you're
wasting all this to study business right
over a safe stable career in the arts
Beach one fair party lay down sure yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
come on I'm not actually gonna go out
with him no he's young successful and
he's hot
gross so what's the deal with my Pheebs
we haven't talked about it yeah keeping
the mystery alive I'm diggin me
sometimes I fear whether I'm even
capable of love welcome to my office
you're making it very hard to judge you
[Music]
someone's going by way too fast I wanted
to see you before we both leave for
school hey I got it go but it have an
export okay Phoebe there's something I
need to tell you
you just went along and you did nothing
I didn't know what to do
I've never been through this before
[Music]
one last summer
the last chance to go all in
I mean what's there to lose right
[Music]
you
you